The jogan Experience so I live in Las
Vegas which happens to be a good town to
think about why the hell can't we
moderate right now when you live there
you see all kinds of wild stuff right
but to me what's always been the
strangest has been the slot machines so
you've spent time in Vegas yeah it's
like they're in the casinos obviously
but they're in the gas stations the
grocery stores the restaurants the bars
and the airp port and they're not
sitting empty right people are playing
them around the clock yeah so I'm like
what the hell is up with that just plays
in your dopamine well and it doesn't
make sense because everyone knows The
House Always Wins yeah it's not uh it's
like a a numbing thing they just sit
there and press the buttons and press
the buttons and press the buttons and
hope they make money yeah so I I decide
all right like I'm going to find out how
a slot machine works why do people get
hooked on slot machines that's the
question and so I go into journalist
mode and I start making calls now the
first group of people that I call turns
out to be a dead end so who I call are
people who are effectively anti-gambling
researchers okay so these are
researchers who have a very
anti-gambling bent and they tell me all
sorts of sort of strange things they're
like oh it's because casinos don't have
clocks they're like these myths we've
all heard casinos don't have clocks uh
slot machines only play in the key of C
which relaxes people and relaxes their
wallet uh casin don't have any right
angles and right angles uh activate
their rational part of your brain and so
I go okay and then I go to an actual
casino and there's right angles
everywhere right the screens are right
angles uh no clocks but guess who else
doesn't have clocks like most businesses
right there's not clocks in Costco most
restaurants right yeah it's not normal
to have clocks and then for the uh the
audio the key ofc I call up a slot
machine audio composer now this is a
real job you can have in Las Vegas right
and this guy goes where the hell do you
hear that he's like I use all keys so I
realized that the problem that I'm
encountering is that I have called
people who want us to stop
gambling I need to call people who want
us to start gambling right I got to
follow the money on this so long story
short I talk to handful of people in
town and this leads me to uh this casino
on the outside outskirts of Las Vegas I
it's brand new it's Cutting Edge but the
catch is that it's not open to the
public so this place is basically a
living breathing casino but it's used
entirely for research on human behavior
what yeah so really who funds that 73
different companies so there's gambling
companies that are involved but also a
bunch of big tech companies who are on
the Fortune
500 so I I go there and it's it's like I
said it's a legit Casino how big is it
it's um I would say I mean it's not the
size of a normal Casino like a sprawling
strip one it's probably about the size
of your everything you have here maybe a
little bigger but they have hotel rooms
it's like a
Walmart that big yeah it's in this big
um office building basically
and they're basically looking at how
everything that happens in a casino
affects human behavior so how does room
design and the technology we're using in
rooms affect Behavior how does Bing with
say an AI bot versus an actual human
impact betting now when I'm there I meet
with to bring it back to slot machines I
meet with a guy who designs slot
machines so the reason that these things
are so entrancing to people it tracks
back to this uh Behavior Loop that I
call the scarcity Loop and this is a
basically a loop looping behavior that
when people do it they tend to get
hooked on it very easy so it's got three
parts it's got opportunity unpredictable
rewards and crook repeatability so
opportunity you have an opportunity to
get something of value so in the case of
a slot machine it's money right uh two
unpredictable
rewards you know you're going to get the
thing of value if you continue the
behavior but you don't know when and you
don't know how valuable it's going to be
so with a slot machine game when those
reels are spinning you could win nothing
you can basically lose your money you
could win a couple dollars or you could
win a life-changing amount of money
there's a fantastic range of things that
could happen and then three uh quick
repeatability you can immediately repeat
the behavior so with slot
machines the average player plays about
16 games a minute and that's different
from all other Habits Like most habits
you don't immediately repeat
them now the reason
that people are so interested in this
companies cin knows is because that this
sort of three-part system I just laid
out it can get people to repeat a lot of
other behaviors too so it's in social
media it's in sports gambling uh it's in
dating apps even companies uh like gig
work economy companies are using it to
get people to work longer hours it's
being leveraged by the financial
industry and a lot of personal finance
apps and on and on and on it's become uh
it's been embedded in so many of the
products even institutions that
influence people's lives because it is
so captivating to us we tend to get
hooked on this three-part
system and so when when you're talking
about like gig economy stuff like uh
you're talking about like uber and
things along those lines driving for
Uber and so how how do they use that so
things like um unpredictable rewards get
put up in front of a driver to get them
to drive into an area of town that Uber
might want them to be in there's also
unpredictable rewards what yeah so like
you might get um say oh if you drive
here like your whatever will you you'll
make x amount more money right it sort
of pops up unpredictably also they'll
they'll incentivize you that they they
offer you more money to go to a
different part of town yeah or dropping
in cues at saying like hey this is where
we are you're going to make more money
today type of thing oh um if you think
about it in terms
of something like social media it's like
the opportunity is to get say status or
likes or whatever it is right and then
say a person posts and then the rewards
become totally unpredictable right you
might get two likes which is like H that
wasn't great or you might get hundreds
of likes which is like oh my God that's
amazing it's the same exact architecture
as a slot machine and then you check and
recheck you're repeating the behavior
all day and
um this Loop the reason that we're so
attracted to it it goes back to
Evolution so I talked to this uh once I
learned how this kind of loop pulls
people in it's really what slot machines
lean on to get people to repeat the
behavior I call up a psychologist he's
this old school dude from the University
of Kentucky who's been studying
psychology since the late 60s his name
is Thomas cental and um he describe he
basically explained this likely goes
back to Evolution and finding food so if
you think out Hunter gathers the thing
you have to do every day is find food
but it's a random it's random whether
you're going to find the food or not so
you go to point a you don't find any
food go to point B you don't find any
food you go to point C no food Point D
oh my God it's a giant berry bush full
of food and that saves your life right
so that search that repeat searching
really pushes us and grabs our attention
because it used to help us survive in
the past oh and there's even I mean if
you want to get down the rabbit hole in
it there's even
um things like what are called near
misses in slot machines which is when
you kind of almost win right you might
two lemons yeah two lemons other lemon
just barely passes by barely passes by
or losses disguised as wins do you know
what those are no so that's when uh
let's say you bet $1 and you quote
unquote win 50 so oh right so you don't
lose everything but you win 50 cents now
we tend to re react to that as if we're
winning when they when they study uh
gamblers and that's also embedded in the
search for food right you might let's
say you're hunting you're like oh we got
a big kill on our hands and then you
whiff and the animal's on its way it's
like damn that is a that's a right
that's the near Miss MH um or you come
up on a berry bush and let's say it took
you you burned 500 calories looking for
this thing and it only contains 200
calories worth of food and so all of
these sort of evolutionary parts of this
system that we used to fall into as we
evolved are now in slot machines and in
turn now being used by a lot of big tech
companies and different Industries so
they just trick the human reward system
yeah yeah mimics these sort of ancient
Pathways more or less and gambling is to
me is one of the most peculiar ones
because um it's so overwhelming for
people that are hooked on gambling it's
such a mental health issue it's such a
an addiction and when you see people
that are just like chasing it and they
just can't stop it's like I always
wonder like what pathway is being
hijacked like what what is about human
beings that want to risk like literally
all of their money on a roll of the dice
or on a spin of the roulette wheel or on
a hand of cards like what is that yeah
this is a good question now this this
Zen guy that I told you about he does a
lot of research on pigeons so he can
basically turn a pigeon into a
degenerate Gambler and like two minutes
he'll give a pigeon a pigeon dude he'll
give them yeah I said the same sounds
cruel I said the same thing when I was
talking to isn't life hard enough as a
pigeon yeah he uh so he he'll get
pigeons who you know they live in these
cages and he'll give them the option to
play a game where they every other peack
they give say 15 units of food so pack
no food pack 15 units of food but then
they have an option to play a second
game and this second game is very much a
gambling game in that they get food
about every fifth peack but it's random
right so you could go PE peack food PE
PE the next one could be food PE PE PE
PE right so it's just kind of like a
slot machine and they get more food
playing the gambling game they get 20
units if you do the math it makes a lot
more sense to play the game where where
you get every other right every other
peack is getting you food it adds up to
a lot more
food but what he finds is that the
pigeons consistently play the slot
machine game 97% of pigeons will choose
that game right but they're not risking
anything they're not risking anything
right but it's still how's that gambling
they're still putting in the effort to
have to play the game yeah but that
seems obvious like the the rewards are
greater so they know that if they just
keep pecking it doesn't hurt to Peck
they're going to get a bigger supply
food they don't get a bigger supply
though because they'll get 15 every
other pack versus 20 every fifth pack so
if you put in 100 packs you're going to
get more food playing the one where it's
you get food every other time right but
it's still not gambling because the
pigeon just sees a larger pile of food
with the more pecs so just wants the
larger pile of food so just keeps going
it's not like they're risking all their
food right right um so I don't think
it's a gambling thing well the larger
the larger pile of food comes from the
predictable reward
yes right if you do every other right
yeah every other is how you would get
the biggest pile of food but you don't
get the biggest pile in one jump one
dump right the one where it's every five
that's a larger quantity of food yeah so
you'd get 20 yeah see that's not
gambling why is it not gambling because
it's just more effort it's more effort
to get a bigger pile so he would argue
that they're just dumb they just can't
say oh it's every other one well all
they see is that they're getting you
know whatever 15 units versus 20 is that
what it was yeah yeah 15 vers all they
know is 20 units like oh this one gives
20 units just keep pecking I don't think
they're smart enough to figure that out
I think they're just like keep going
keep Oh's 20 keep going keep going 20
but there's not a risk so here's what
I'll tell you he would argue and a lot
of biologists would they would say you
know there's this Theory called the
optimal foraging Theory says that
animals will expend the least amount of
energy to get the most amount of food
all right so over time they're expending
a lot less energy to get get more food
and so here's where it gets interesting
though is that to sort of bring it back
to why do people fall into this why
would someone bet their entire fortune
on a roulette will or whatever is that
when he will put pigeons in a sort of
wild environment so where he keeps them
is in these pigeon cages where they kind
of live alone it's you know it's a basic
cage when he puts them in a cage that
mimics the wild so it's this giant cage
that has like roof it's got Cliffs it's
got other pigeons it's very much like
they would have to live in the wild and
then he throws them back to choose a
game they start choosing the optimal
game oh interesting
yeah